e allora d'affitto è questa oggi fate a
fare la spesa o fa che ospita un po
particolare cioè si chiama abete di
manfredonia non si chiama comunque è un
abete e alle grazie
ecco questo è il backstage chiaramente è
un road movie
diretto da tim burton
non è che ce l'ho
di pasqua
diciamo che è un po storto e salute un
po come la torre di pisa pende da un
lato scopriremo sulla casa da cuore
ma deve farlo
una strada tra martina
presenti alla rampa poteva essere quella
lasciata molto semplice ma proseguiamo
il nostro viaggio nel mondo del natale
allora questa beta e una verde verde
silver perché anche delle sfumature si
deve riscoprire the passion di realtà e
non però un po andremo a twitter harlow
perché no per niente
tutti a casa mia avete visto come
trasportato l'albero è stata una cosa
molto divertente molto particolare e
adesso andiamo al sodo quindi fare
l'albero ecco faceva notare che io ho
vinto spesso premi in apertura di
scatole perché come vedete ho una grazia
una dote particolare nel proprio
sventrare le scatole proprio in generale
lo sono a numero di prede biscotti tante
altre cose
ma torniamo a noi forbici a punta
arrotondata come direbbe tonio cartonio
della previsione lauzi non era da
riprendere in mano ormai l'impatto è
niente eh no vabbè comunque restare in
casa ragazzi in amicizia proprio come se
fosse i nemici licata
diventarmi non fare l'albero allora sarà
divertente ripulire tutto lo sporco che
sta saldando anche in faccia bene allora
un pezzo che ho fatto ma il cammino si
apre e bellissimo forse sapete che forse
il primo albero vero che ho problemi a
vita allora questo alzarlo ma pesanti da
di centa e non so se farò ok l'albero
c'è ecco diciamo che me lo aspettavo un
po più dritto diciamo che è un po come
la torre di pisa vende a destra
lo portiamo dietro
scarichiamo sul mio letto ridatemi i
soldi basteranno questi balocchi perché
insomma non facendo numeri di un po di
anni non sapevo quantificare le modalità
di calcio non verbo ma soprattutto una
volta a roma tra l'altro pd io ho capito
all'occhio prima dell'albero quindi
siccome sono per natura non troppo
grosse che mi basteranno alla fine
l'altro abbastanza grosso
vediamo se non sarà troppo vuoto a
premessa i colori dell'albero allora di
solito mi piace molto rosso e oro del k
qualche attrito l'oro è un peccato che
la mia cucina e sono a riprendere perché
tutta disordinata venivo faremo dopo
manata al volto per vita e di colori
comunque argento grigio quindi bianco
quindi mi sono sentita come costretta
per diciamo bene comune a prendergli
argento bianco quindi non lo sarà bianco
argentato che uno guastando lavoro nero
bianco argento oro nero giorgio via
progetto marina nuova si nuovo singolo
in uscita a natale non è vero però però
però questi colori da shin food snom one
works office
il nodo sulla mappa iniziamo con il
primo balocco a caso allora da dove si
inizia io tipo un po inesperta in questo
momento un po inesperta in questo
momento brava la prima pallina di pesca
regola sono levare le reti degli alberi
dal peso per sempre nella chiaramente
nella classica indifferenziata
citata ma guarda avrà oltre classici
volo chi crede litteram venisse
parcheggi di questi cuori che tra super
ciro simonetti impressioni messi mi
trasformo un po in quel personaggio come
ho capito e nei buchi allora dicevo
abbiamo quasi finito le palline i
balocchi e abbiamo aggiunto anche queste
pigne che io non pensavo di mettere
nell'albero perché sono appunto un po
dorate però alla fine
nel complesso ci stanno bene dalla pole
il tocco shine che non ci sta per niente
male
quindi direi che sono approvate
mancano dunque dopo di che facciamo
mettere i cuoricini
le cucine e le vicine allora se magari
poi il caso del profilo e lo possono
riempire ancora un po però non sapendo
appunto che albero a comprare non ho
voluto esagerare però poi magari un rito
allora arrivato il momento clou ci
diciamo che abbiamo riempito abbastanza
no adesso manca le luminarie che prima
era in camera mia perché come sapete io
ho una passione per le lucine quindi non
è che ne tiro fuori solo a natale
diciamo che sono evergreen per quanto mi
riguarda i nonni sono dappertutto
adesso favino persone compreso un albero
finto ma deve arrivare il momento di
pannello bundles come
[Musica]
allora ragazzi vi devo aggiornare perché
dall'ultima crisi sono passati due
giorni e in questi due giorni ho
sconvolto tutto perché l'angolo non è
più dove era prima ho cambiato posizione
dell'albero per una questione di voci
prese ci precede e soprattutto suonata a
comprare dei nuovi balocchi perché mi
sembrava un po bonino fu preso queste
qua trasparenti con i disegni bianchi
poi ho preso le stelline un po
glitterato è così che sono super super
carine e poi i fiocchi di neve argentati
per atelier belli e poi delle piccole
dei piccoli balocchi insomma molto
simili a quelli che avevo già grandi
però sono più piccoli sono perfetti per
riempire insomma di buchi che dovevano
essere riempiti
un'altra cosa che mancava oltre ai
balocchi insomma per riempire l'albero
era la punta perché a me non piacciono
tanto le punte quelle classiche lunga
eccetera eccetera il momento di solito
sull'hardware volevo qualcosa di più
originale quindi appunto in questo
negozio di pochi trovato questo è un
altro che aveva proprio questi colori
bianco argento e ha detto ma perché la
facciamo un bel fiocco come punta
dell'albero e quindi ecco a voi la mia
punta dell'albero celi un fiocco che io
l'adoro
mi piace molto come sta con la trovo
molto molto chic mon.do magica può
vedere l'albero
e luce fu nel mentre ha pure inizia la
verità dei ragazzi top spero tanto che
vi piaccia mio albero
insomma questione e mezzo fa luci spente
e fatemi sapere come
mi piace e soprattutto tenetevi pronti
perché arriveranno tantissimi nuovi prof
[Musica]